monsieur bernard arnault votre parole
publique et hérard et notamment sur la
question des économies que des médias la
commission apprécie donc que vous ayez
pu vous rendre disponible dans des
délais relativement brefs pour démonter
moynier devant ted vous êtes président
directeur général et actionnaire
majoritaire du groupe lvmh leader
mondial de l'industrie du luxe je ne
peux pas citer l'ensemble des marques
que vous détenez et qui incarne la
france à l'international peut-être juste
louis vuitton dior tiffany mais
également le château yquem l'un des vins
les plus prestigieux du monde ce n'est
cependant pas pour cette raison
peut-être malheureusement que nous
allons que nous nous réunissons ce matin
mais nous vous avons demandé de venir ce
jour pour votre engagement dans les
médias il remonte à 1993 avec le rachat
du quotidien économique la tribune puis
l'hebdomadaire investir en 2007 vous
avez cédé la tribune et fait
l'acquisition des échos puis du parisien
et du parisien magazine en 2015 pour
constituer la holding les échos le
parisien présidée par pierre louette que
nous avons entendu le 2 décembre dernier
en plus des titre éponyme le groupe
détient radio classique et le mensuel
connaissance des arts tu pas exhaustif
dans la présentation des des titres mais
peut-être que le rapporteur il reviendra
si nous avons souhaité vous entendre
monsieur arnaud c'est parce que vous
incarnez avec et quelques autres les
grands capitaines d'industrie et
extérieurs aux médias qu'ils choisissent
d'y investir ce qui constitue une
spécificité française qui n'est pas
nouvelle qui est assez ancienne mais qui
est évidemment mérite d'être de notre
pas
étudié la commission est donc très
impatiente de vous entendre aujourd'hui
je vous propose l'organisation qui est
celle que nous suivons en fait à toutes
nos auditions je vais vous donner la
parole pendant 10 minutes en vous
demandant de respecter les dix minutes
tout simplement parce que après nous
avons un certain nombre de deux
questions à vous poser
et en fonctionnant sous forme de
questions réponses le dialogue sera sans
doute plus vif et plus animée et ce qui
vous permettra à travers de bien sûr nos
question d'aborder des points que vous
n'aurez pas pu aborder dans les dents
les dix minutes
les liminaire je précise que 7 12 10
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat et elle fera
également l'objet d'un compte rendu qui
sera publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme qu un faux témoignage devant une
autre commission denquête seraient
passibles des peines prévues aux
articles 434 13 14 15 du code pénal je
vous précise également qu'il vous
appartient le cas échéant d'indiquer vos
éventuels liens d'intérêts ou conflits
d'intérêts en relation avec l'objet de
la commission denquête
je vous invite monsieur arnaud a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je te jure
je vous remercie et je vous donne donc
la parole pendant dix minutes
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs
vous me fait parvenir cette invitation
pour vous parler d'un sujet et je vous
en remercie qui sont les médias et
l'organisation capitalistique
ce sujet est assez marginal
tenir pour que l'on sait pour le groupe
que dirige
j'espère donc que mes propos pour
vous éclairer suffisamment car cette
activité n'est pas ma spécialité et je
me contact caveau consacre qu'assez peu
de temps néanmois depuis le début des
années 90 comme le président minable
rappeler lorsque j'ai pris la direction
du groupe lvmh
j'ai pu d'une part approcher la réalité
économique de leur fonctionnement mais
aussi leurs difficultés lorsque la
conjoncture est délicate ou que leur
position concurrentielle et moins
pertinente j'ai pu tirer de ces
constatations quelques idées quant au
rôle de l'actionnaire
que je suis heureux de vous présenter
brièvement avec mon oeil et
d'entrepreneurs avant de répondre à vos
questions d'abord quels sont les
contours du groupe de presse propriété
de lvmh vous l'avez rappelé c'est
essentiellement quatre tritre de presse
écrite les échos le parisien investir
sens des z'arts mais aussi des médias ou
division audiovisuel autour de radio
classique essentiellement autour de la
musique classique avec meet the medic
chuter v entre autres se sont aussi
quelques grands salons par exemple
vivent à tech qui donne à la tête
française un rayonnement mondial
et ce sont en tout plus de 1600 salariés
dont 144 carte de presse et le chiffre
d'affaires tout tourne autour de 400
millions et malheureusement les pertes
sont
substantielles cet ensemble s'est
constitué lentement et sans plan
concerté les titres concernés ont été le
plus souvent proposé au groupe ares
propriétaires qui souhaitaient s'en
défaire soit parce qu'ils avaient échoué
à trouver des repreneurs aussi passionné
que soit parce qu'ils ne pouvaient plus
faire face aux besoins réguliers de
liquidités
lvmh a ainsi acquis radio classique en
99 alors que pierre faure le président
de la sagem qui l'avait qui en était
propriétaire qui était un ingénieur les
passionnés de musique classique que
cherchait un repreneur connaissance des
arts pour 2000 lorsque la famille qui le
détenait a souhaité s'en séparer les
échos en 2007 quand le groupe anglais
personne voulait le vendre et qu'il
était alors possible de faire revenir en
france ce qui est le premier journal
économique français le parisien en 2016
lorsque la famille amaury a estimé ne
plus pouvoir en assumer la charge
particulièrement lourde pour l'avenir et
récemment sallanches dont claude
perdriel un ingénieur comme moi mais qui
a fait de la presse une des passions de
sa vie et qui est très soucieux de voir
son oeuvre de presse s'appuyer sur des
soutiens solides a souhaité que lvmh
reprennent la part minoritaire
appartenant au groupe renault qui
voulait la revente
alors pourquoi me direz-vous le groupe
lvmh a acquis tous ces titres les échos
le parisien connaissance des arts radio
classique investir et les autres sont
dans leur domaine des fleurons des
titres dont les noms résonnent dans la
culture collective depuis plus de
cinquante voire 200 ans ce sont des
références
pluriel diverses respectés qu'ils sont
indissociables des domaines de il couvre
la vie économique et sa compréhension ne
seraient pas les mêmes je crois sans les
échos la vie quotidienne locale et
nationale ne serait pas la même sans le
parisien aujourd'hui en france qui en
assurent la couverture la culture des
marchés financiers l'attractivité des
entreprises ne seraient pas aussi
diffusé en france sans investir et la
couverture des événements artistiques ou
musicaux ne serait pas aussi riche sans
connaissance des arts ou radio classique
ils sont dans des domaines différents
irremplaçable c'est pour cela que le
groupe lvmh a accepté de temps à autre
de conforter tel ou tel titre s'il est
une référence incontournable il nous
paraissait en effet nécessaire et dans
l'intérêt général devrait à sa pérennité
aurait-il survécu s'ils n'avaient pas
reçu l'investissement d'un actionnaire
comme lvmh vous me permettrez d'en
douter compte tenu du nombre de médias
qui ont disparu depuis 20 ans et de
l'ampleur des révolutions technologiques
actuels leur avenir en dépit de leur
qualité était pour le moins à mon avis
un certain
on assiste en effet depuis une dizaine
d'années à un bouleversement mondial est
majeur dans le domaine des médias de
plus en plus de personnes en particulier
chez les jeunes je vois chez mes enfants
remplace la lecture des journaux des
magazines ou la télévision par le regard
quotidien sur les écrans sociaux
planétaire à travers leur smartphone ou
encore des écrans de netflix et consorts
de plus la publicité dépensé dans les
médias traditionnels est en chute au
profit de ces nouveaux médias à
l'audience croissante et mondial
la pérennité des titres traditionnels
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui est donc
loin d'être assurée à terme
elle le serait encore moins je le pense
si ces médias n'avaient pas
d'actionnaire puissant capable de les
aider pour faire face à ce défi
structurel absolument fondamental qu'il
n'est pas évident de surmonter et qui
nécessite qu'ils affrontent et des
investissements considérables
permettra des fleurons français de
briller c'est ce qui anime depuis
toujours élevé match vous connaissez les
maisons du groupe président a eu
l'amabilité et d'en citer quelques-unes
je ne devais pas allonger la liste il y
en a 70 depuis la création du groupe
lvmh mon équipe a concentré toute son
ascension pour bâtir le premier groupe
de luxe mondial autour de cette maison
artisanale prestigieuse pour l'essentiel
française
nous employons aujourd'hui 175 mille
personnes dans le monde dont un peu plus
de 40000 en france
le groupe année plus de 106 de
production des manufactures artisanale
en france il est le premier contributeur
à l'impôt sur les sociétés dans notre
pays bien que son chiffre d'affaires
soit pour l'essentiel plus de 90%
réalisés hors de france lvmh a également
une place importante dans le mécénat
avec notamment la fondation louis
vuitton
tout cela était possible en s'appuyant
sur les valeurs qui animent notre groupe
et qui sont au nombre de quatre jeux les
sites succinctement pourrait évidemment
développé ces thèmes qui sont
passionnantes d'abord la créativité et
l'innovation
ensuite la recherche permanente de la
plus haute qualité
l'esprit entrepreneurial indispensable
au succès économique est la motivation
personnelle et enfin l'engagement
sociétal sociale environnementale qui
donne un sens à notre action
notre relation aux médias s'inscrit dans
cette démarche
investir dans les talents dans
l'innovation insuffler de la créativité
dans leur héritage patrimonial et un
esprit de responsabilité dans leur
gestion alors même si l'activité meda ii
constitue qu'une toute petite partie la
réalité économique du groupe nos valeurs
s'applique t elle et c'est sans doute
pour cela que c'est ce que je pense qu'à
travers les dernières décennies nous
avons été à plusieurs reprises sollicité
les vendeurs les cadres et les
journalistes concernés voyons sans doute
chez lvmh un ensemble de valeurs qui
leur correspondent
pour conclure cette introduction par un
mot sur le rôle de lvmh en tant qu
actionnaire du groupe de presse les
échos le parisien je dirais qu'il
consiste essentiellement à accompagner
l'adaptation de cette entité face face à
la concurrence de plus en plus forte des
médias numériques planétaire qui
prennent chaque jour plus d'importance
pour les lecteurs les auditeurs les
annonceurs au détriment des médias plus
traditionnels que sont le prête presse
écrite radio ou la télévision le rôle
fondamental de l'actionnaire lvmh pour
ce faire consiste à aider le groupe les
échos le parisien à investir puissamment
dans les outils d'avenir le web le
mobile les nouveaux formats afin de ne
pas se laisser éclipsé trop vite par les
médias numériques mondiaux qui sont
chaque jour plus puissant et plus suivis
par nos concitoyens
pour y parvenir le plus efficacement
possible au plan opérationnel
lvmh a donné à la direction de son pôle
média dirigée par pierre louette que
vous connaissez une totale autonomie là
même qui caractérise la méthode de
gestion décentralisée de notre groupe et
qui s'appliquent à chacune de ces
maisons
voilà quelques mots
un proxy messieurs arnaud pour cette
présentation nous allons revenir à
travers nos questions sur un certain
nombre de points que vous avez
abordé dans votre présentation que nous
allons commencer les questions par celle
du rapporteur david assouline 9
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
vous avez exposé
les activités que vous avez dans le
domaine des médias
linverse d'une audition qui a eu lieu
hier ce n'est pas l'ampleur de ces
acquisitions qui
fait l'objet
de votre témoignage devant notre
commission denquête c'est à dire une
énorme concentration dans le domaine des
médias car la liste est est relativement
brève
les échos le parisien aujourd'hui en
france investir radio classique
d'essence des arts mais aussi
boursier.com
c'est des des prises de contrôles
ciblés
et
avait quand même des ambitions me dit on
est jeudi
en ce moment dans d'autres d'un show sur
d'autres médias on y reviendra en tous
les cas ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
vous êtes
là un instant on a dit la
plus grande fortune du monde
votre groupe est puissant il a des
activités de nombreuses employés dans le
monde
un succès incroyable et même dans ces
moments de pandémie de
il augmente ses bénéfices de façon tout
à fait incroyable
donc
on a du mal à penser que une activité
qui est plutôt vous avez dû capitalisées
et c'est parce que
n'est pas bénéficiaire du tout
dans le dans le domaine des médias et
alors que ce n'est pas votre métier ça
vous l'assumez vous avez choisi de
d'investir dans des médias comme ça pour
pour faire oeuvre de
d'intérêt public d'intérêt général
bien entendu qu'il doit y avoir un
intérêt dit aussi à vos activités
et c'est ça notre interrogation c'est
comment pourquoi des
grands industriels dans des domaines
tout à fait différent vous c'est le luxe
mais il ya le btp pour l'un il ya
l'armement pour l'autre et c'est à vous
intéresser aux médias
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser un
peu plus cet intérêt
notamment avec eux ce qui est sûr dans
le débat public sur la place publique et
même avec des faits que je citerai
quand on dit que c'est un moyen d'
influence
que c'est un alors vous pouvez appeler
ça le rayonnement
pour
moyens d'influencé aussi un moyen de
contrôler un peu ce que l'on peut dire
de bien ou de mal sur les activités
commerciales que vous avez
dans la presse que répondez vous à cela
leveaux lvmh
s'intéresse comme je les dis dans ma
petite introduction
au fleuron français
ces groupes de presse en sont partis
quand il s'agit d'investir dans ces
groupes de presse
qui représente certes une activité
déficitaire mais extrêmement faible on
valeur absolue par rapport à l'ensemble
du groupe
il nous est apparu nécessaire et
dans l'intérêt général
de le faire d'autant que
sinon certains ces titres n'aurait
peut-être pas survécu et que
vous parler d' influence
notre gauche n'a aucune relation
économique avec les pouvoirs publics les
marchés publics tous à 90% plus de 90 %
de notre chiffre d'affaires se fait hors
de france donc on voit mal en quoi
une activité
comme celle là que j'en mangerai plus
tôt en ce qui me concerne
je veux pas être péjoratif d'ailleurs
mais du côté du mécénat peu
nous donner une influence quelconque
en ce qui concerne la meinau affaire qui
n'est en rien lié aux pouvoirs publics
fonctionnaient je sais bien qu'il y a
une opinion générale qui est de dire les
investisseurs
dans la presse sont des hommes de médias
qui veulent intervenir
mais dans quel but en ce qui nous
concerne on vois pas l'objectif
l'objectif pour nous c'est de faire en
sorte que ces entreprises réussissent à
redevenir
rentable
d'ailleurs ce qui est atteint
aujourd'hui cette année pour la première
fois depuis dix ans dans les écoles est
de faire en sorte que ce petit groupe de
presse
prosper voilà et
jeu
c'est notre objectif il ne va pas plus
loin
vous savez que il ya eu un certain
nombre de reproches dans la façon dont
vous avez interférer dans des activités
de presse je donne plusieurs exemples
vous souvenez à la suite de cette une de
libération vous concernant
vous avez supprimé l'ensemble de la
publicité de lvmh
avec 150000 euros de publicité en moins
pour le quotidien de la part du rau en
novembre dont c'était en septembre 2012
en novembre 2017 il y avait une enquête
du monde etc
toujours concernant les parts des spurs
et
[Musique]
le monde a été privée de publicité aussi
pour une hauteur estimée à 600 mille
euros
vous confirmez
que ça peut être des
vacances qui concerne libération puisque
vous avez vu la lune en question est ce
que vous aviez le sur le sénateur
l'affût en question
ça vous avait paru tout à fait normal
d'avoir un titre aussi agressif contre
la première entreprise française pour
une motivation fausse parce que j'ai
jamais eu l'intention de devenir
résident fiscal belge se situe
fantasme encore une fois
ça vous aurez plus d'avoir ça et non
seulement il fallait accepter cette une
et
on faisait quasiment jamais de publicité
dans libération les lecteurs de
libération sont pas les clients du
groupe donc on a dit voilà on s'est
vengé en faisant plus de féliciter
maintenant faisait déjà quasiment pas
donc tout ça c'est
alors je me suis plaint effectivement
j'ai appelé le directeur de l'époque 7
mai qui s'était dans les dix ans à
libération maintenant c'est incroyable
de pouvoir traiter
des plus grosses entreprises françaises
et son actionnaire à son dirigeant de
cette façon c'est pas peut-être que vous
trouvez ça bien mais c'est rien mais je
ne suis pas là pour vous dire si je
trouve ça bien ou pas bien et d'ailleurs
je
absolument
le droit plein et entier d'être choqués
d'être pas d'accord avec la façon dont
la presse peut traiter ou votre personne
ou vos activités mais le sujet que l'on
traite la
indépendamment des personnes c'est le
sujet des possibilités par la puissance
économique ou financière
d'utiliser cela pour interférer sur la
liberté de la presse parce que il ya
d'autres moyens si c'est ce que je vous
avais est-ce que vous avez d'autres
exemples je veux fini sur le monde je
vous dis c'est fou et sur libération de
toute façon faisait pas de publicité
alors vous voulez le problème du bien
obligé moi je vais vous répondre et je
répète je répète ce que vous avez
d'autres réseaux sociaux nature puisque
vous êtes d'autres exemples me montrer
alors ensuite il y a quelque chose qui a
fait un peu plus l'actualité c'est ces
derniers jours d'ailleurs
mais je pense que ça vous reconnaîtrez
il y a eu
d'embauchés on va dire en tous les cas
de missionné
par votre groupe
monsieur bernard croire square cini pour
enquêter sur la vie privée et sur la vie
tout court de monsieur rufin qui était
en train de faire un film qui va
s'appeler merci patron plus tard je
répète je ne juge pas telle ou telle
chose je suis factuelle que je vous pose
la question la justice a
acté le fait qu'il y avait eu cela et a
proposé que moyennant le versement de 10
millions que vous avez accepté la sphère
seraient closes
me confirmer cela pourquoi comment
qu'elle suit vous avez donné vous même
dans votre entreprise à
cette affaire alors neuf dans cette
affaire d'abord
il faut savoir que c'est la justice qui
a proposé aux services juridiques
d'élever les matches cette formule de cg
saisies étaient peu fade 2
d'accord
conventionnelle mention général est
d'intérêt public on n'avait pas demandé
c'est le juge qui l'a proposée aux quais
et dans ce document que vous pouvez le
consulter nous n'avons reconnu aucune
culpabilité
donc je réfute toute culpabilité ce qui
a été approuvé par la justice française
dans ce dossier
si vous n'essayez d'insinuer qu'on est
coupable en quoi que ce soit dans cette
affaire c'est aux sénateurs je vous
invite à lire la décision de justice
je répète je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
dans un dialogue personnel avec vous je
10 ce qui est et je vous demande de
réagir justement je vous donne la
possibilité de donner des explications
et donc je vous avais accepté de donner
10 millions pour quelque chose où il n'y
a aucun sujet pour vous c'était comme ça
le juge nous a proposé cette transaction
afin d'éviter que nous soyons
pris dans cette affaire à laquelle on
n'avait rien à voir et notamment ont
fait une responsabilité
quant à monsieur de fin sur une femme
tout le monde connaît c'est quelqu'un de
très brillant qui est d'extrême gauche
et pour lequel le groupe lvmh depuis
toujours
est un épouvantail bien alors pourquoi
sommes nous un épouvantail parce que
nous sommes français parce qu'on en
baisse en france parce qu'on crée des
ateliers en france et que c'est un
contre-exemple tellement flagrant pour
sa stratégie de communication qu'il est
obligé d'essayer de trouver des poux
dans la tête partout et si on a essayé
d'éviter que monsieur rifai lors d'une
assemblée générale où il avait prévu de
venir pour enfarinée tout le monde je
puisse entrer dans la salle
franchement non pas le problème non mais
je crois qu'on n'est pas sur le mali le
sur la même longueur d'onde de réflexion
je répète ce qui nous intéresse ici
c'est de voir les possibles
interférences
de puissance économique sur la liberté
d'expression la liberté de la presse des
faits que je parle les invente passe pas
moi qui étais les chercher ils sont là
et donc ce que je sais c'est que
monsieur rufin dans cette affaire lui
n'accepte pas le jugement c'est à dire
qu'il veut et que vous vous vous
l'acceptez vous donnez 10 millions
uniquement parce que vous considérez que
c'est une
c'est à dire que maintenant c'est
quelqu'un
vous attaque alors que les faits sont
infondées pour pas que d'affaires c'est
ça pour pas qu'on en parle et bien vous
donner des millions je ne pense pas que
c'est complètement comme ça mais la
presse a documenté les choses chacun se
fait une opinion mais j'aime moi j'ai eu
votre réponse et ça et c'est
on peut continuer cette audition sur des
questions qui touchent un peu plus à
vous me confirmer que vous êtes encore
une participation dans l'opinion avec le
journal opinion le journal l'opinion
à un investissement tout à fait
minoritaire dans l'opinion c'est moi
j'ai
24,8 pour sue
ensuite il ya la régie publicitaire
comment la régie publicitaire du groupe
le parisien les échos agi visa line et
marques du groupe lvmh
comme la régie publicitaire
de tous organismes de presse on est dans
des relations ont été marquées elles
essayent de les convaincre
d'acheter des publicités doit entendre
dans leur nom est d'ailleurs si je sais
pas si vous avez posé la question à
pierre louette mais il se plaint
régulièrement les fait que nos marines
investissent pas assez et plus dans
d'autres médias donc problème là c'est
plutôt le fait le groupe est sous
investisseurs prêts à tort aux autres
dans les magazines du groupe et ça vous
pouvez le vérifier je peux vous donner
les chiffres
pouvez vous nous préciser les raisons
qui vous ont poussé à dénoncer le pacte
d'actionnaires qui vous lie à arnaud
lagardère en septembre dernier autre
autres acteurs industrie mais qui est
investi dans la presse
arnaud lagardère signe de soutenir jeudi
soutenue est on arrivé à un moment où
il avait choisi un autre partenaire de
tous pour son organisation
capitalistique donc
je crois qu'on a été associé
dans une société en commandite et qui a
été ensuite transformés dans une société
normale donc à partir devant il y avait
plus de commander et plus tellement
d'intérêt
d'avoir d'accord particulier avec lui
puisqu'il devenait président directeur
général cgt anonyme si je me rappelle
bien la structure qui a été fait
alors que c'est sur le sur le même sujet
parce qu'il est très très biais à
la
y compris à l'audition que nous avons eu
hier et que nous aurons plus tard avec
monsieur lagardère
pour qu'on comprenne bien il compte y
compris ce qu'il va se passer pouvez
vous nous dire bon vous étiez vous
partisan de
prendre
les parts chez lagardère que finalement
bolloré à monsieur bolloré a obtenu
pouvez vous nous raconter un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé à votre avis en tous
les cas au moins votre avis ce ce qui a
fait
un autre choix était fait par monsieur
lagardère
et pensez-vous inévitable loupé à qui
aura lieu le mois prochain probablement
lagardère sur
2,2 du groupe bolloré sur le groupe
lagardère europe 1 paris match
journal du dimanche et les maisons
d'édition
pour écouter
quand enfin nous lagardère m'a appelé et
deux ans c'est parce qu'ils étaient
confrontés un activiste si je me
rappelle bien qui était entré dans son
capital maintenant demandé si j'étais
prêt ça c'est pas une vm à chasser la
société familiale
participer dans sa société
personnelle en commandite et celle de
pommes trompait enfin on était donc là
pour le souvenir et face à cet
actionnaire
activiste ensuite les choses ont évolué
et finalement je crois que
arnaud lagardère a passé un accord
qui est maintenant tout à fait public
avec le groupe de vincent bolloré est
donc notre présence dans cette société
là c'était moi
évidente et nous sommes aujourd'hui
actionnaire petit actionnaire froid 10 %
de la société
anonyme qui résiste voilà voilà à peu
près
il y a une à congo rites et souvent dans
nos réflexions parce que
sur la question des aides à la presse
pensez vous que ces aides à la presse ou
distribués de façon juste et équitable
alors que votre groupe qui a quand même
une certaine sécurité
et le de loin encore le principal
bénéficiaire avec
ils ont déjà un peu plus de deux fois
plus que le deuxième qui en bénéficient
qui est le figaro et le monde
[Musique]
après soit le principe
vous avez peut-être
réfléchi qui serait de faire de la
discrimination entre tel ou tel titre
parce que son actionnaire est plus ou
moins solide ça je vois pas très bien
comment ça peut se justifier ou on fait
des aides à la presse et à ce moment là
il faut que ça se fasse de manière un
peu vague mais nick où on en fait pas du
tout ce qu'il peut aussi se défendre
mais
après comment vous allez choisir entre
tel actionnaire ce qui est assez solides
tel autre il est moins solide donc on va
donner - enfin on est partis dont
quelque chose
j'ai juste le principe on valoir à ceux
qui en ont le plus et plus à se tourner
ou le moins ternes être qu'on peut
imaginer ça
ben moi je suis partisan de garder un
système à peu près également réparties
ou de le supprimer complètement
voudrais revenir sur les conditions et
économique vous avez bien décrit dans
votre propos liminaire
le contexte économique des médias en
disant que c'est un secteur économique à
la rentabilité faible ce qu'on veut bien
entendre parce que ça corrobore un
certain nombre de témoignages qu'on a eu
jusqu'à présent de
deux personnes qui sont venues dans
cette commission denquête tous sauf un
qui hier nous a dit au contraire
chiffres à l'appui que la rentabilité
opérationnelle était forte dans le
secteur des médias il a
un sens bolloré pour
elle le nommer qui nous a donné des
chiffres sur la marge d'ebitda en
moyenne en disant qu'il y avait deux
secteurs particulièrement rentable le
luxe et les médias l'automobile les
cosmétiques intervenants loin derrière
les chiffres sont assez étonnants et ne
correspondent pas à l'analyse que vous
avez un jeu ne pas vous demander de
commenter des chiffres qui ne sont ils
ne sont pas les vôtres mais est ce qui
est une possibilité de rendre l'activité
média financièrement rentable
alors je pense qu'il ya moyen de la
rendre rentable d'ailleurs je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure les échos sont
actuellement l équilibre donc on essaye
de faire en sorte que le reste revient
aussi à l'équipe quant au fait que ce
soit le deuxième secteur le plus
rentable après le luxe je pense que
vincent bolloré a raison mais il fait
référence à ces grosses sociétés
mondiales qui sont des sociétés de
médias si vous prenez facebook si vous
prenez
microsoft maintenant qui est en train de
se développer là dedans face les
sociétés extrêmement rentable donc est
d'ailleurs une des questions on avait
laquelle il sera intéressant de il
réfléchit c'est pourquoi ces sociétés là
ont été créés aux états unis et en
europe je pense que c'est ça le problème
plutôt que je peux interférer sur les
débats du sénat mais plutôt de se
concentrer sur les entreprises
françaises qui existent actuellement qui
sont difficiles au niveau de leurs
résultats qui sont aidés par des gouttes
financier capitaliste
alors on peut critiquer on doit dire oui
van maele faut pas leur prêter des
arrière pensées en ce qui me concerne en
a pas mais bon mais le problème de fond
c'est quand même que l'europe perd son
leadership depuis des années depuis le
début des années 2000 pourquoi facebook
a été créé aux états unis avaient pas
été créés en europe c'est ça le vrai
problème auquel il faudra réfléchir on
avait c'est peut-être là dessus que
enfin je fais pas de conseil à vous
donner mes
réunions temps kate sénatoriale pourrait
être très intéressante je serai prêt à
venir il participait à nouveau aussi
volé
pourquoi on a raté ça qu'est ce qu'on
n'a pas fait dans notre pays ou en
europe en général pour que des
entreprises comme ça se crée ici il n'y
avait pas de raison que ça secret aux
états unis alors maintenant un peu plus
de start-up un peu plus ça commence à
s'accélérer et on est partis va-t-on
après sa vrai sujet mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas tellement celui le sujet de
notre commission denquête quoique notre
problématique est aussi de faire
ancêtres et des vrais leaders mondiaux
dans le domaine des médias et qu'ils
soient d'origine française ou d'origine
européenne et on voit bien qu'il ya
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de bots
groupement qui sont en train d'opérer
cessé ces derniers mois une ces derniers
mois je pense à à tf1 et m6 par exemple
et l'argument des responsables de 2 td
des responsables de tf1 est clairement
celui que vous énoncez c'est à dire
faire émerger un leader
je pense qu'ils ont raison sans doute
100 cède mon avis ne sais pas et je
pense qu'ils ont raison de ce point de
vue je voulais vous interrogez parce que
évidemment compte tenu de la puissance
de votre groupe on nous avait précisé la
stratégie mais qui est une stratégie
assez prudente sur la question des
médias on peut en comprendre les raisons
on vous prête aussi beaucoup d'intention
à tort ou à raison donc c'est le moment
peut-être de clarifier les choses on
vous a notamment on a cité le nom de
votre groupe sur l'acquisition de m6 et
puis également sur le site du figaro est
ce que c'est des interrogations des
strates des options que vous avez étudié
auquel vous avez finalement renoncé à
leur écoute et sur
m6 on n'a pas étudié le dossier on nous
l'a on les a sollicités parce que compte
tenu de la taille du pot
quand un gros dossier se présente
on nous contacte mais on n'a pas étudié
quant au figaro j'ai dû encore hier que
le monde disait qu'on avait fait une
offre et ça c'est quand même très
étonnant ça vous montre quand même les
limites de la presse
c'est faux
je leur ai dit à plusieurs reprises
je le confirme aujourd'hui sous serment
est néanmoins ils écrivent ils
continuent à les créer c'est quand même
étonnant nous n'avons jamais fait
d'offre sur les gares
etc reprise systématique pendant les
articles comme celui vous avez vu
non mais ça montre quand même les
limites et voyez ma capacité d'influencé
limitée ce qui montre aussi qu'il ya
peut-être des coups à prendre quand on
s'engage trop dans les médias
de toute façon c'est moi j'ai l'habitude
aussi de me faire attaquer
la réussite d'un groupe économique en
france
c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
est bien vu je le regrette c'est dommage
certains autres pays
font de ces groupes des héros bon en
france pour s est plutôt cachée et
on se fait critiquer quand ça marche
bien on se fait encore plus critique et
même si on emploie beaucoup de monde
même si le groupe en question ont beau
jeu fut dix mille personnes par an en
france même si on est le premier
contributeur aux impôts français et
critiques que j'ai vidé crif on a créé
la fondation nous évitons êtes peut-être
pas suivi les critiques qu'on a uvré
pour ça le dis on faisait ça pour éviter
la peau pour faire on a dépensé près de
800 millions on fait des expositions y
en a une en ce moment qui ne le serait
très bien ok ça c'est pas quelque chose
qui est rentable à tenon passe quelque
chose qui coûte parce que pour faire
venir une collection pareil
les musées russes
ça se fait pas tout seul
faut des contreparties mais je pense que
pour la france c'est formidable c'est la
première fois qu'une collection comme ça
il apparaît
néanmoins on est critiqués quand j'ai
fait un don pour le reste reconstruire
notre dame je pensais que je me dis
c'est là tout le monde a trouvé ça bien
ben non non vous pouvez critiquer mais
non ils auraient mieux fait de donner ça
aux impôts et que l'état le pays comme
ils sont importants mais je vous dit
juste
et à un état et peut-être que ça
explique aussi pourquoi les grands
entrepreneurs potentiels
les jeunes les chercheurs cetera
devant cet environnement vont du mal à
aboutir en france
si je peux me permettre dans
l'environnement politique quand je vois
ce à quoi les responsables politiques
sont soumis en ce moment ça décourage
pas mal évocation des bons sentiments
vous avez autour de la table des gens
qui ont encore la vocation ils vont vers
la
je vois
déjà certains d'amis dans cette je sais
c'est difficile les maires les maires
qui sont attaquées sont là et
ça décourage un peu je suis donné la
parole à m mes collègues maintenant pour
une première c'est pour l'heure question
j'aurais manganèse merci président
bonjour monsieur arnaud si j'en juge par
le nombre de photographes que qui vous
attend dès ce matin et si j'osais je
dirais que c'est un luxe de vous
recevoir ici au sénat
vous avez fait référence tout à l'heure
à votre vision d'entrepreneurs et à
titre personnel c'est bien celle là que
je viens chercher ce matin et dont je
crois nous avons bien besoin au sein de
la commission denquête
votre réussite et celle du groupe est
totalement exceptionnel
et les françaises vous l'avez dit fait
croyez bien qu'un bon nombre
de personnes en france en ont conscience
elle ne tient pas au miracle elle tient
à la fois au travail acharné à
l'intelligence et à la détermination
vous avez donné d'ailleurs les quatre
axes principaux de façon globale de
votre stratégie
et je crois qu'en cette période
électorale
je pense qu'elle serait ces quatre axes
serait bon à rappeler à tous les
candidats et candidates aux élections
présidentielles la créativité
la haute qualité
l'esprit d'entreprise
l'engagement et vous avez même rajouté
après ce à quoi nous sommes
excessivement attaché ici au sénat
la gestion décentralisée
et dieu sait si nos deux pays a du mal
avec ça alors ma question elle est
relativement simple
la concentration qui nous tient dans
cette commission enquête c'est un sujet
économique
le pluralisme lui c'est un sujet de
démocratie alors comment à votre avis
concilier la nécessaire recomposition du
marché des médias
avec la non moins nécessaire
préservation de ce pluralisme qui fait
vivre la démocratie
on est dans un pays où les médias sont
libres
aujourd'hui si on veut faire sortir un
journalisme fait ressortir en aparté que
négatifs sur le président de la
république
sur premier ministre sur
un responsable politique un article
négatif sur un dirigeant d'entreprise
qui peut le faire évidemment il faut que
ce soit dans steam fondé ou avec des
arguments il peut le faire on est quand
même dans un pays où la liberté de la
presse la liberté de la communication
est assurée
je pense que
il faut pas exagérer l'impact que
pourraient avoir
certaines opérations de rapprochement
par les deux défunts de m6
vous parlez d'autres
les intervenants
je ne vois pas
pourquoi
de telles opérations
pourraient changer la liberté qui est
fondamental de la communication en
france et l'esprit français
il y aurait de telles protestations de
tel
ça ne marcherait pas et donc l inverse
si on crée beaucoup de réglementation
complémentaires
et la france est aussi un pays
peut-être dans les affaires en général
dans les entreprises les réglementations
augmente augmente tous les ans et de
vienne doit être un échantillon des
réglementations de tous ordres
ça n'est pas favorable
à la prise d'initiative au lancement
d'entreprise donc je serais assez
prudent moi je peux pas vous dire ce
qu'il faut faire mais je serai ce
prudent de rajouter encore une couche de
réglementation complémentaires
non parce que ça va ça va freiner les
initiatives
alors
je ne peux pas le bouchon plus loin
parce que je peux vous dire quoi faire
c'est pas c'est pas mon métier encore
une fois les médias c'est pas ma
spécialité
est ce que ce que je pense qu'il faudra
essayer de se mettre en situation de
favoriser s'il doit y avoir des nouveaux
médias internet ita de favoriser leur
apparition leur création leur
développement à partir de france où dort
c'est c'est quand même ce qui manque
parce que aujourd'hui moi je vois mes
enfants mais
il espère un jour
il n'a pas été et regardent leurs écrans
donc c'est le pelage les des gens qui
regardent date et à arrêter d'augmenter
la publicité illicite et aujourd'hui moi
je vois dans d'autres où on a bougé
complètement des médias traditionnels
aux médias internet et les sommes
maintenant on fait plus de la moitié des
investissements
et ça ça a changé en dix ans sur les
médias internet au détriment
des magazines certains d'ailleurs sont
au bord de la catastrophe économique
donc
une nouvelle réglementation extrêmement
contraignantes ce serait quand même un
peu attention voilà michel logique merci
monsieur le président bonjour
c'est vrai que dans une ambiance assez
morose de la france actuellement
aggravée par la pandémie ça fait plaisir
de recevoir ici les personnes qui font
rayonner la france de manière plus que
positive dans le monde entier
justement
cette commission des requêtes nous
permet de recevoir beaucoup de grands
noms de l'industrie française
donc vincent bolloré lagardère xavier
niel patrick drahi vous même je
trouverais ça vous l'avez un petit peu
effleuré mais j'aimerais connaître
vraiment qu'est ce qui attire selon vous
les plus grands industriels
dans les médias ça c'est ma première
question baptisé mes questions ça serait
de vous avez parlé de changement d'usagé
on ne l'est plus les journaux des même
façon vous avez fait référence à vos
enfants n'écoutent plus la radio de la
même façon ne regardent plus la
télévision de la même de la même façon
donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez de nouvelles ambitions
le président l'info vous a
interrogé sur m6 et sur le figaro mais
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres choses parce
que vous êtes limité à cette réponse là
mais elle souhaite d'autres ambitions
vers d'autres médias ça c'est ma
deuxième question est la troisième
puisque l'avait évoqué plusieurs fois ce
sont les grandes plateformes vous avez
dit planétaire pas glop à 10
interventions planétaire justement
est-ce que vous ne serez pas intéressé
pour créer une plateforme planétaire
bon alors qu'est ce qui attire les
investisseurs dans les médias
je pense que souvent
c'est des propositions en tout cas en ce
qui nous concerne ce qui leur arrive
on nous sollicite
nous dit pourquoi vous voulez pas
nous aider dans telle ou telle situation
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec vous
l'avez rappelé le seul président avec
arnaud lagardère
c'est ce qui s'est passé récemment quand
mon ami paul perdriel
devait trouver quelqu'un qui achetaient
la participation minoritaire c'est
encore lui qui dirige complètement le
challenge passif et ses amis dans les
terres détenues par renault et préférer
probablement que ce soit
des excellentes relations que six mois
six prov donc c'est chez nous en tout
cas c'est un long processus
on sait pas c'est un long processus et
ça reste extrêmement petit par rapport à
l'ensemble du goût donc c'est pas
quelque chose
comme nos recherches entreprises dans
développement externe
mondiale on a acheté et certainement
l'année dernière une entreprise
américaine donc
d'être tiffany qui est la première
marque américaine une des premières
marques mondiales de joaillerie pour ça
c'est un très bon investissement et donc
pour moi personnellement je pense à
beaucoup de temps à ces affaires là et
et leveaux
beaucoup moins
aux autres opportunités dans les médias
alors lesquels vous pourrez faire dans
l'avenir ça dépend de celle qu'on va
nous proposer
pour l'instant
je peux répondre
boum-boum autant dé mam excusez moi
c'est oui c'est le masque un sas et le
masque cette fois blême des mousses plus
on m'a donné un masque spécial
l'impression qu'il est moins et le son
se transmet mois
donc
pour
les la suite d'une manière générale si
vous lui en donne pas nos projets alors
je sais bien qu'on ait deux une
assemblée tout à fait spécial
aujourd'hui mais de même que deux ans
mais mes actionnaires je ne donne pas le
projet
voilà mais tout cas les deux vous avez
évoqué ne figure pas dans la halle et
ceux des projets alors démarrer des bars
et une
une société
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on
participe depuis longtemps dans toute
une série de start up je sais pas si
vous le savez vous savez peut-être pas
mais par exemple être flix en 2000
j'étais à des actionnaires le départ de
felix on avait pratiquement dans mon
groupe familial près de 20% de cette
société et d'ailleurs c'est très amusant
parce que l époque de business model
n'avait rien à voir ils envoyaient par
la poste des petits dvd que vous louiez
pendant un mois et que vous leur envoyez
est le fondateur m'avait expliqué mais
maintenant avec le développement de
l'internet et tout ça on va faire de la
vidéo on demande de l'avoir ça va être
le nouveau système et ça a marché
après
moi je peux pas je peux pas faire ça je
peux participer
et des finances et par mon groupe
familial des créateurs
qui doivent avoir la flamme et l'idée
parce que ce qui compte dans une
lancement de startups comme ça à la fois
l'idée et après c'est la mise en oeuvre
c'est d'ailleurs quand vous regardez
facebook c'est d'ailleurs assez étonnant
de voir que à l'époque où ils ont du
coeur balançait facebook
pas mal d'autres sociétés avec la même
idée et se sont lancés en même temps est
la seule qui ait marché
vraiment c'est facebook parce que
l'exécution était parfaite et c'est donc
dans les entreprises c'est la même chose
dans mes entreprises liées à l'idée il
ya la créativité il ya le le créateur
génial
mais après il faut exécuter et si
l'exécution est pas là
ça beaucoup moins de choses de
fonctionner mais moi ça m'intéresse
beaucoup regarde d'ailleurs des stats on
est actionnaire actuellement de la
première la plus grosse l'icône
française il s'appelle black
bear market et qu'ils ont qu'ils ont des
sur le site internet et des téléphones
reconditionnés qui en plus à côté
écologique
non mais ça c'est passionnant assez
mauvaise mais ça m'intéresse énormément
mais je vous garantis pas de faire un
facebook français
monique de marco
c'est merci pour ces précisions monsieur
arnault il pour motos médicis mans avec
black market c'est à dire une entreprise
qui ont peu apprécié par sa volonté
justement travaillé sur le recyclage
mais là sont à mes questions je
souhaitais rebondir sur deux questions
qu'a posées david assouline
celles concernant la transaction de
votre groupe lvmh sur moyennant la
condamnation pour espionnage sur le jean
el fakir un constat aucun des journaux
dans vous êtes propriétaires comme les
échos le parisien non relayé cette
information
peut-on considérer ceci comme une forme
d'autocensure ou un non événement c'est
ma première question
ma deuxième question votre groupe les
échos le parisien qui est aussi
propriété de lvmh a capté en 2010 9 24%
des aides directes à la presse vous
critiquez souvent l'intervention de
l'état le service public et les emplois
publics néanmoins votre groupe se taille
la part du lion pourrait-on dire dans
les aides publiques sur sur les serbes
sur la presse n'y voyez pas une
contradiction
telma question
alors concernant
les aides je crois que j'ai répondu si
vous voulez les aides
elles sont réparties en fonction de
chaque titre une certaine méthode
on peut critiquer ça consiste en un mois
de régler le problème je ne suis pas
quant aux
offenses que les journaux du groupe
n'ont pas cité
l'accord transactionnel qui a été c'est
ça la question moi ça j'en sais rien
franchement je ne sais pas
ce que c'est quand même un non événement
plus moi je ne sais pas il faudrait
poser la question j'en alice a dû être
pris dans d'autres tournois ça c'est
pareil en tout cas bon je suppose qu peu
de ça
je n'ai pas je n'ai jamais absolument
pas de commentaires à faire là-dessus
[Musique]
evelyne renault garabédian merci
monsieur le président monsieur arnaud je
vous êtes à la tête du plus grand groupe
industriel de luxe dans le monde que
vous avez construit patiemment avec
comme tout capitaine d'industrie une
vision d'en arriver à terme à ce que
vous souhaitiez vous avez bâti un empire
de la culture française qui rayonne dans
le monde je vous avoue que moi j'en suis
très fier
malheureusement en france la réussite
n'est pas toujours où je dirais même
rarement vu d'un bon oeil encore moins
admirer ou cité comme exemple notre
commission aujourd'hui elles portent sur
les liens entre la concentration des
médias et la démocratie moi j'ai une
question simple à vous poser est ce que
vous pensez que vous ne seriez pas
attaqué de la même manière si vous
n'aviez pas des activités dans les
médias ou bien pensez vous qu'il s'agit
tout simplement d'un argument
supplémentaire merci de votre réponse
non je pense que je suis critiqué
malheureusement
en contrepartie de la réussite du groupe
et il médias au niveau de la réussite
économique
encore une fois il n'y contribuent pour
une somme négative donc
la critique malheureusement et elle
n'est pas général non plus il faut pas
exagérer mais dans toute une série
d'interventions de responsables
politiques vous en citer un tout à
l'heure
c'est pour presque
mauvais de voir la réussite d'une
entreprise française c'est
qu'aujourd'hui lvmh est la première
entreprise européenne
l échelle mondiale d'ailleurs c'est pas
non plus énorme on est plus petit que
les géants dont on parle les facebook et
et et compagnie mais
c'est une réussite économique
qui est en france qui s'appuie sur
la création d'emplois qui s'appuie sur
le développement
de l'artisanat on a un travail pour la
formation des artisans français on à
l'institut des métiers d'excellence qui
forment les milliers d'artisans pour
essayer de conserver ses métiers en
france
tout ça c'est extrêmement positif et
laisse et reconnu comme tel par une
bonne partie de l'opinion mais
c'est vrai que les critiques
sont dérangés par les succès français
d'une certaine façon alors est ce que le
fait d'avoir des média augmente ou pas
les critiques on a vu c'est un peu
indifférent je pense jouer
je pense
julien pas rejetant qui est derrière son
écran je viens
jour à savoir le ton sénateur de paris
merci monsieur arnaud de votre présence
et les citations pour la fondation et
les très belles expositions qu'elle est
l'organisme c'était un plus énorme pour
la capitale de la france alors en
octobre dernier la société des
journalistes des échos a demandé au
directeur de la rédaction à ce que la
mention propriétaire des échos quoi
systématiquement à poser quand son site
et votre groupe lvmh
erding ou ses filiales ces règles qui
proviennent d'une charte éthique adopté
il ya une dizaine d'années manque
parfois de visibilité que pensez vous de
ce type de charte que fait votre gros os
les rendre plus lisibles trouvez vous
normal on indique à chaque fois vos
fonctions lorsque vous êtes cité dans un
article est de même pour le parisien que
vous possédez depuis 2015 qui ne sait
pas lui doté de type de telles charges
est ce que vous pensez qu'il serait plus
simple plus lisible et bien à chaque
fois que vous êtes mentionné pour éviter
les débats que qui ont été cités dormant
dans cette commission que tout
simplement on rappelle que vous êtes un
propriétaire de tel ou tel journal au
moment où vous êtes cité s'est fait
parfois pour certains propriétaires dans
certains journaux est mais pas
systématiquement que pensez vous de ce
sujet merci aux gonds
pour tourner sur le sénateur que c'est
appliqué même non pas rien et que même
aujourd'hui dans le parisien quand on
parle
du groupe lvmh pour
moi ou des projets il ya toujours une
mention propriétaires les valises je
n'ai pas d'exemple en tête tout ça n'est
pas été fait voyez donc je suis d'accord
avec ça
jusqu'où ça normal et je pense que c'est
fait
sylvie robert
oui merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur arnaud alors je vais continuer
donc sur ces phénomènes de concentration
qui ne sont pas nouveaux c'est pas
depuis hier depuis avant-hier mais
effectivement si cette commission
denquête s'est mise en place et que
sont des phénomènes qui prennent de
l'ampleur et qui peuvent un moment
interrogé sur la question mes collègues
lundi du pluralisme ou de la démocratie
on a vu dans déjà beaucoup d'auditions
que nous avons effectué des motivations
qui sont des motivations d'ordre
économique très clairement dos des
motivations d'ordre peut-être
idéologiques voire politique où nous
avait dit
moi ce qui était important par rapport
aux valeurs du groupe c'est de pouvoir
répondre aux propositions que l'on m'a
fait pour sauver je le dis sauver je ne
sais pas s'il faut employer ce terme les
fleurons de delà de notre culture on va
dire française et parallèlement et c'est
un sujet très important dans ce contexte
l'évolution des usages des grandes
plateformes font qu'à un moment on
s'interroge sur ce qui va se passer
demain et je voudrais du coup vous poser
de questions très simples est-ce que et
vous l'avez dit dans nos traditions je
ne demande pas un avis
tout de suite sur la question de la
fusion
tf1 m6 mais vous avez dit je pense
qu'ils ont raison
ça m'amène à vous poser une question
elle penser qu'aujourd'hui il faut
encore plus concentré
donc pour pouvoir parce que c'est quand
même ça être en capacité de lutter ou en
tout cas par rapport à cette grande
plateforme numérique est ce qu'on en a
encore les capacités
ou parce que c'est une des motivations
qui qui qui qui est énoncé c'est à dire
que face à face à ce contexte là il faut
devenir de plus en plus gros et du coup
est ce que vous dites vous ne pensez que
c'est ça a du sens et du coup ma
deuxième question est ce qu'au contraire
parce que ces phénomènes interroge
questionne sur ces questions de
pluralisme il ne faudrait pas peut-être
inventé un autre modèle qui permettrait
justement parce qu'on a toujours été
attaché la question la diversité dans
notre pays on le voit dans d'autres dans
d'autres domaines d'ailleurs je pense à
la musique par exemple
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas au
contraire et là du coup en tant que
législateur c'est important pour nous de
vous entendre inventer un autre modèle
qui permettrait non pas de concentrer
mais de travailler sur des seuils d
travaille sur des garanties qui existe
déjà un mais d'aller au delà pour
pouvoir ou alors des participations
qu'ils soient un peu différente en fait
le modèle économique de la presse
aujourd'hui qui permettrait de donner
une valeur ajoutée à ce contexte qui
vous l'avez dit n'est pas ni français ni
européen mais américain
voire même et sur lequel on a quand même
du mal à aujourd'hui à lutter merci
écoutez moi je pense
effectivement
le problème de la télévision c'est
l'apparition d'une concurrence
internationale
disait planétaire
de toutes ses
créations relativement récente youtube
netflix cette erreur qui exerce une
concurrence
très forte par rapport à
la télévision classique
qu'elle est l'inconvénient d'une de
concentration
et quel est son avantage l'inconvénient
que vous envisagez j'imagine c'est au
niveau de la communication
de tout ce qui concerne
les journaux télévisés terra qui
seraient regroupées
savoir quand même que veut aujourd'hui
je suis pas là pour défendre tf1 j'ai
absolument pas parler aux gens de tf1
mais c'est tf1 sur ce plan là même si le
niveau
dash
téléspectateurs augmente régulièrement
ils sont quand même en tête très très
nettement et je crois que m6 sur la
partie communication ils sont pas
extraordinaires montois donc
l'union faisant la force en matière
économique pour lutter contre
ces nouvelles plateformes
je pense qu'ils sont mieux de réunir
leurs efforts plutôt que d'avoir de
cette quantité c'est pareil et
la télévision aujourd'hui
ce qui intéresse le plus me semble-t-il
qu'on aime c'est le sport et les films
et pour faire ça il faut des moyens de
plus en plus gros justement parce que
amazon
est ce qu'on veut laisser amazon diffusé
de manière exclusive les matchs de foot
français je sais pas peut-être est-ce
que la formule 1 qui en reprend de
l'intérêt doit être diffusé en dehors
d'eux
en france en dehors des des chaînes
françaises donc plus
un groupe télévision a les moyens
d'investir plus il a les moyens de faire
face à sète à cette concurrence là moi
je raisonne comme ça il sans connaître
vraiment le sujet un sommet je me suis
jamais intéressé est tellement la
télévision vous ai dit tout à l'heure
même si ce n'est pas regardé le dossier
bon mais
c'est un réflexe d'entrepreneurs
et les craintes que vous avez
est quand même de moins en moins de
jeunes moi je vois mes enfants est ici
aujourd'hui
il regarde pas le journal télévisé
et donc d'ici 25 ans
qui va regarder journée ses visées ne
s'est pas un
donc
tout ça
tout ça il faut pas non plus
se laisser trop marquée par un syndrome
de
problèmes que qui a trait à la vous avez
raison à la démocratie mais démocratie
en france quand même là on est un pays
de grande liberté d'expression nous
semble-t-il
[Musique]
bien martial r
merci monsieur
arnaud pour vos explications donc vous
comprenez que nous adhérons sur le
problème de la concentration des médias
avec le risque qu'ils encourent pour la
pluralité de l'information
et la deuxième chose c'est pour la
défense pro 7 et permettre la poursuite
de la liberté de création en france et
du rayonnement de la culture française
alors vous vous nous dites intervenir un
peu par mécénat ont dit que ça peut
c'est un domaine des médias qui peut
être profitable
mais pour gagner comme ça des parts de
marché enfin pour conquérir le monde est
ce que on peut
continuer voilà à défendre et à faire
vivre une culture française ou bien au
contraire pour répondre aux demandes
d'une clientèle
s'internationaliser et finalement
diluer notre culture dans une culture
mondialisée bukit connaissait bien ça
avec le luxe est ce que vous pensez que
ta culture française elle peut résister
à
justement à cette dilution
dans des groupes qui pourrait rivaliser
avec les grands groupes mondiaux ou au
contraire est-ce qu'on va ipek qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour qu'on puisse
garder c'est à dire est-ce que
simplement ça doit passer par du mécénat
pour continuer à faire vivre
notre culture et nos particularités
françaises et européennes bien
la culture française
est évident qu'il faut les médias
français participe à son développement
et d'ailleurs je crois que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
au canal + par exemple finances
énormément de films français et que
toute cette activité là contribuent
au développement de la culture française
maintenant
c'est aussi difficile de faire face au
succès énorme des films américains que
l'on voit partout et on peut pas les
interdire on peut pas faire comme
certains pays qui imite un production à
leurs propres
créations
quand il ya également une question de
concurrence
des créations et je peux dans nos
métiers c'est la même chose mais en trop
me
mondialement des marques françaises qui
ont
un appel extraordinaire sur la clientèle
internationale aux états unis en chine
au japon en mai
quelquefois
sont créées par des créateurs qui
travaillent avec nous ils ne sont pas
forcément français la créatrice de
christian dur actuellement est une
italienne
donc mais elle défend de manière
formidable la marque christian dior et
arrive à lui faire atteindre un degré de
désirabilité dans le monde
exceptionnel donc et on avait
une dizaine d'années un autre créateur
chez dior qui était aussi non français
et un anglais donc il s'appelait john
galliano qui lui aussi avait apporté un
souffle créatif formidable donc la
culture française et elle est restée est
dur c'est une marque française ont ce
qu'il faut c'est arrivé à arriver à
faire ça maintenant au niveau de
la culture
pur littéraire aussi médium
cinématographique
c'est probablement plus difficile à
cause de la langue est d'ailleurs en
errant qu'il faudra essayer de trouver
développer un peu le visage de la langue
française qui devait être la langue
normalement utilisés
à bruxelles et maintenant tout se passe
en anglais alors que les anglais sont
sortis à ce sujet
bien leur a pris
bonjour monsieur arnaud
d'abord une remarque préalable à
l'adresse de mes collègues parce que ça
s'est déjà dit hier quand on a reçu
monsieur bolloré il ya pas les français
qui aiment l'art y fit française et ceux
qui l'aiment pas moi je vous croise pas
tous les matins des français qui n'aime
pas la réussite française ou peut-être y
en a beaucoup vous en croisez beaucoup
mais personnellement j'en croise pas
beaucoup de ce type là par contre c'est
vrai qu'en france yens passion de
l'égalité
et que quand des gens gagnent énormément
d'argent et que d'autres ont du mal à
vivre mots il ya une attention française
à cette question il ya des gens qui
peuvent aimer la réussite française est
pensé que ça se résume pas au cac 40 qui
peuvent aimer la réussite française et
on sait que monsieur arnould devra payer
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
c'est pas tout ça n'est pas
contradictoire
mais la question de la commission
laquelle normes et puisque ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'on entend ces
remarques et que notre audition et
retransmise c'est pas inutile quand même
deux mettre les points sur les i sur
cette question
une remarque aussi préalable vous avez à
plusieurs reprises ça a été abordée
balayé d'un revers de main la question
de la condamnation enfin deux pas de la
condamnation de la convention judiciaire
que vous savez signé avec la justice
on peut quand même s'étonner puisque
vous avez l'air sûr de vous sur
l'innocence de votre groupe de payer
quand même 10 millions d'euros pour
éteindre une procédure judiciaire 10
millions d'euros c'est quand même
beaucoup d'argent on va évidemment on
n'a pas vous et moi exactement le même
rapport à ce que représente 10 millions
d'euros mais c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent
donc si vous étiez si sûr de vous
pourquoi avoir accepté l'extension cette
procédure judiciaire on peut quand même
sens en étonner
ensuite je voudrais revenir sur la
question
de la concentration le problème chez
arnaud c'est que vous n'êtes pas seuls à
être propriétaires de grands journaux et
finalement vous êtes très peu nombreux
aujourd'hui
vous monsieur bolloré à monsieur dry fut
niel donc en fait quelques grandes
fortunes quand on fait le compte
possède l'essentiel aujourd'hui du
paysage médiatique français et tdc là
qui est un sujet qui nous amène à
débattre de la question de la
concentration
donc en fait les règles dans ce monde là
se font avec une influence importante
de ces propriétaires là vous ne pouvez
pas dire par exemple que renvoyer comme
ça la question des aides à la presse
parce que quand quand on discute de
savoir s'il faut réformer les aides à la
presse les journaux vous possédez
donnent leur avis sur cette question et
si tous les journaux possédé par ses
gros de le même avis c'est à dire il
faut pas réformer les aides à la presse
elles ne sont pas réformées aujourd'hui
elles sont profondément inégalitaire et
on pourrait effectivement imaginer
l'autre avec d'ailleurs il ya d'autres
qui ont existé par exemple on a créé à
une époque une aide au quotidien à
faibles ressources publicitaires elle
est aujourd'hui très faible
alors qu'on sait que la publicité est
une arme économies très importantes pour
l'existence ou la non existence des
journaux donc oui vous avez un avis sur
ces questions là vous avez un avis à
travers les titres que vous possédez
aujourd'hui vous avez de l' influence à
travers les titres que vous possédez sur
la question des aides à la presse sur la
question de faut-il ou non renforcé les
lois anti concentration
faut-il ou non réformé la répartition de
la publicité qui fait vivre ou fait
mourir des titres de presse aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes un acteur de cette
question vous ne pouvez pas juste dire
parce que vous voit défiler les
empreintes de foot dit mais moi je suis
un tout petit acteur de sa semoule au
reine rania tout vraiment tout petit
petit vous êtes tous tout petit mais le
problème c'est qu'au total vous êtes 4
ou 5 à tous possédés
donc vous ne pouvez pas dire que les
décisions qu'ils sont et non secteur
vous n'y est pour rien donc
effectivement nous pensons enfin nous
sommes un certain nombre à penser que il
faudrait sûrement se pencher sur les
règles actuelles parce que nous voyons
le paysage se rétrécir le paysage
démocratique se rétrécir et ça n'est pas
le fait de mettre en cause les titres
que vous possédez mais au total le
paysage se rétrécit le nombre de titres
se rétrécit les questions de pluralisme
son sens à ce poser et part de très loin
la confiance des citoyens s'érode donc
il faut changer des règles et vous
pouvez pas jusqu'à dire faites confiance
à quelqu un grand champion qui vont
résoudre tous les problèmes
effectivement les problèmes le mécénat
comme vous avez dit ne suffira pas à
faire vivre durablement le pluralisme de
la presse voilà ce qui nous préoccupe
ici
si vous voulez réagir ou pas
non monsieur laurent a posé plusieurs
questions
[Musique]
très brièvement
sur il dit vous avez beaucoup d'argent
le fortuné ces terrains
comme le signaler et vous faire
remarquer que l'essentiel de ce qui est
recouvert par ce terme ce sont les
actions du groupe lvmh et comme ce
groupe grâce à tous ses employés ses 175
1000 employés dont plus de 40 millions
france non plus 5 et 10 mille recruter
tous les ans avec 100 sites industriels
c'est que vous êtes attentifs à ça 100
sites de manufacture artisanale en
france 500
sous traitants bon grâce à la réussite
de toutes ces équipes qui est travail de
quarante ans
ces actions beaucoup monté
mais c'est pas sur mon compte en banque
je sais d action qui servent à l'outil
industriel donc il faut pas confondre et
celui qui a gagné au loto et qui peut
elle est dépensé et un industriel comme
moi qui a dix actions donc il va le
faire c'est vrai le total vos chers mais
elles sont là elles sont inamovibles je
ne peux pas les utiliser pour mes
dépenses personnelles g ils sont partis
de l'actif industrielle de la france est
probablement plus belles entreprises de
notre pays et qui d'ailleurs fait la
fierté de ses employés vous qui êtes
attaché au vous ouvriez terrain vous
savez très bien que
une employée qui rentre chez vuitton
pour elle c'est formidable elle a un
salaire supérieur à ceux qui sont payés
dans son environnement et là un travail
tout à fait intéressant et c'est
vraiment extrêmement valorisant et
d'ailleurs
construisez des ateliers régulièrement
voilà donc vous dire quand ça fait ce ce
terme de richesse oui d'accord ça vaut
d'argent mais c'est un outil industriel
c'est pas de l'argent sur un compte en
banque alors les dix millions qu'on a
payé d'abord je vais rappeler tout à
l'heure
ça c'est une demande qui nous a été
faite par la justice alors pourquoi on
accepter
nous avons été
dans le papier qui a été signée
reconnu non coupable
mais si on ne faisait pas ça
on était embarqué dans un procès par
ricochet sur fins et tous ces gens là se
seraient amusés à nous mettre dans ce
procès qu'on aurait probablement on en
serait sortie et en os attendait et
c'est moman il n'y aura pas de jugement
vous avez éteint la procédure aux jeux
laissez moi finir le titre bic est la
logique ce procès aurait duré plusieurs
années pendant plusieurs années le nom
du groupe ont été mêlé à une histoire
c'est pas exactement lesquels
alors qui est utile qui elles continuent
de procédure et on a effectivement
préféré éviter ça éviter d'avoir le nom
du groupe traîner dans la procédure
judiciaire pendant plusieurs années
alors qu'on n'avait rien à se reprocher
et on a accepté à la demande du juge de
payer cette somme voilà et qui est
qu'est-ce qu'il est qu'ils allaient
celle du groupe étaient abordables et
c'est tout c'est pour éviter de quelque
sorte abîmé un petit peu l'image de
votre dans un procès bon alors après sur
la concentration tout ça c'est vrai que
l'on peut on peut en discuter
en centration
moi je pense que les actionnaires
aujourd'hui ils sont très utiles à
l'avenir
de des médias dont ils sont
propriétaires en particulier nos médias
et qu'est ce qu'on essaye de faire je
pense que père louette avait voulu
expliquer pour rouler d'auditionner on
essaye de les transformer dans le monde
numérique pour justement arriver à
conclure ans est ce cette concurrence
énorme d
dia américains et pour faire ça ça
nécessite beaucoup de moyens
et on arrive petit à petit on quand on
est arrivé au au quotidien o au parisien
est quasiment pas d'abonné numérique
aujourd'hui on a près de quarante mille
abonnés et et ça augmente très vite fait
et c'est ça qu'il faut vous développez
mais ça ça coûte beaucoup d'argent et
aider les abonnés numériques vous savez
ça va prendre beaucoup moins ceux qui à
chaque journal tacler
vincent capo-canellas ce merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur arnaud de
votre d'autres éclairages faut d'abord
rappeler que l'objet de la commission
dans lequel j'avais sous les yeux c'est
de mettre en lumière les processus ayant
permis nous pouvons aboutir à une
concentration dans les médias
en france et d'évaluer l'impact de cette
concentration sur la démocratie je le
dis parce que on a abordé de ci de là un
certain nombre de questions de procédure
il semble-t-il sont closes et qui me
semble un peu étrange et à l'objet qui
est celui de votre présence
je veux rappeler qu' on est nombreux à
être conscients que nous avons besoin
d'investisseurs et que nous aurons
besoin de capitaine d'industrie et bravo
au groupe fait rayonner la france quoi
alors ceci posé dans les médias
particulièrement il ya le sujet qui est
celui de la commission bancaire c'est à
dire la concentration dont on nous dit
depuis lundi puisqu'on a eu un
professeur d'université on a eu un de
vos collègues investisseurs on comprend
que la concentration est effectivement
un sujet qui peut avoir une utilité
notamment pour résister face aux géants
d'internet et pour promouvoir le les
valeurs démocratiques française à
l'étranger bois alors comment on règle
ça parce que en france on a un peu peur
de la concentration et tout le monde
nous dit effectivement si vous regardez
on n'est pas très gros
mais est ce qu'il ya une amélioration à
conduire pour faire que cercle et de la
concentration mais que sur la question
de des rédactions l'indépendance et et
des rats est-ce qu'on peut pas apporter
une pierre qui donne garanti c'est un
peu la première question est deuxième
question tout à l'heure vous avez un peu
esquissé sujet comment vous voyez la
capacité collective de la france a
résisté face au géant d'internet
qu'est-ce-qu'il qu'est ce qui lui manque
gardot
sur la première partie donc
comment comment faire l'édifice est moi
je ne suis pas les législateurs j'ai
déjà du mal à ce que je pense oui c'est
que
chaque journal chaque média quand même
une ligne
[Musique]
et
cette ligne est
il faut quelques pas par exemple
les échos les échos c'est un journal
économique qui est
un défenseur ou un illustrateur de
l'économie de marché
et en tant qu'actionnaire c'est une
ligne laquelle on a adhéré après ce sont
les réactions qui la met en eux
le parisien c'est un journal der et
populaire
plutôt
général
qui est globalement
un journal de nature à seissan test mais
assez oecuméniques dont lequel les
électeurs
s'intéressent essentiellement faut quand
même le savoir aux sports et aux faits
divers d'ailleurs leur parti qui fait
qu'ils aillent très bien fait je sais
pas si vous avez lu récemment les
articles sur les différents assassinats
les foulées propre procès
c'est très très bien fait bon ok donc ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que quand
tant qu'actionnaire
ça me va très bien après le journal est
responsable parce que ce que ce qu'il
faut éviter c'est se mettre dans une
situation où l'actionnaire se trouvent
parce que c'est pas les nouvelles
réglementations éventuels sont trop
compliqué ou
trop stricte
se mettre dans la situation où la ligne
change
et par exemple si demain
je prends se trouvait avec un parisien
qui devient un journal
sur un extrême ou sur un autre
il faut que les actionnaires puissent
réagir on aime
pas je n'ai pas envie d'avoir un journal
qui deviennent
financer un journal qui deviennent le
le support d extrême droite ou de gauche
s'il ya une indépendance
absolue totale on sait jamais donc il
faut quand même qu'on puisse réagir un
moment ou un autre de même si je prends
un exemple c'était plus une maison si le
pas si les échos demain devait défendre
l'économie marxiste qui me plaît
peut-être le seul on sait rien
mais quand même c'est quand même
extrêmement gênée
bon
il faut que tu aies des garde-fous
l'époque il faut rien changer mais je
pense qu'il ya des garde-côtes et des
garde-fous pardon excusez moi oui je
suis d entendre bien entendu tous les
mois c'est ce masque un c'était bon
c'est enfin voilà et alors que la
deuxième question était sur le
comment faire pour
les géants d'internet pour l'instant je
pense que la seule façon de résister
c'est justement de renforcer ceux qui
peuvent le faire c'est à dire de
d'augmenter la présence internet de tous
ces médias et que les français
investissent dans les startups en
espérant que la prochaine la prochaine
vague en niçois ont dit soit vraiment
associer parce qu'on a raté la
précédente la yona une nouvelle avec le
métavers lnf t il à vous avez suivi sans
bien sûr
essayons d'être à temps
g
dans votre intervention à l'instant vous
avez fait une référence à un actionnaire
qui se trouverait dans une situation où
la ligne éditoriale d'un média
changerait je ne sais pas si vous
faisiez référence à un média en
particulier j'ai bien compris que
c'était pas les ce que vous contrôlez
mais cette remarque est parfois faite
sur ces news à propos de ces news le
fait qu'ils aient eu un changement de
ligne éditoriale avec un une orientation
politique plus marqué vous n'êtes pas de
commenter l'orientation de ces news mais
est-ce que si ce cas de figure se
se révéler c'est à dire que quelqu'un
qui utilise en fait un média pour faire
passer des lignes politiques extrêmes
est-ce que vous comprendriez que le
régulateur
interviennent de manière plus marquée
qui ne le fait jusqu'à présent
je pense qu'il faut faire tout ça avec
une grande prudence parce que ça peut
aller dans un sens ou dans un autre et
se révéler aussi contreproductif il faut
faire attention moi je vous donner un
exemple
théorique de ce qui pourrait arriver et
dans le sens il faut quand même que les
actionnaires puissent réagir et
l'actionnaire ne soit pas mis au point
un voilier avec
une rédaction qui d'un seul coup font
des raisons diverses se met complètement
diverger et sans pouvoir rien dire ces
voiliers c'était c'est quand même si si
demain je vais pas faire ça mais je
finance et moi un journal the lancet moi
même un journal en étant à la tête du
journal bon pas c'est autre chose je
ferai les choses mais là
la direction est complètement
données de manière indépendante
une équipe c'est le cas actuellement
pierre louette il gère tout ça
voit rarement ils étaient vous le dire
très rarement
dernière question de du rapporteur
oui
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
changer sur le fond c'est aussi
l'occasion d'avoir des échanges a avec
des industriels sur sur l'économie d'un
secteur donc
le débat franchement c'est n'est pas de
considérer que parce que l'on pose des
questions
qu'on exerce un droit aussi de critiques
cela veut dire que l'on essaye de
dévaloriser ou de critiquer de façon
systémique on va dire une réussite
française
je suis très très fier quand
des sociétés d innovation des créations
des sportifs des artistes français
rayonne dans le monde et quand je me
promène dans le monde je suis très
heureux qu'on dise du bien de telle ou
telle chose que l'on fait et plutôt que
l' inverse
et d'ailleurs faut arrêter aussi la
petite musique que y a qu'en france
qu'on critique comme ça ailleurs ils
sont très fiers d'eux il ya des gens qui
critiquent aux états unis leurs fleurons
toute la journée c'est le propre des
démocraties et les seuls endroits où on
critique pas d'ailleurs les puissants du
pays on va dire qu'ils soient
économiques ou politiques ce sont dans
les dictatures ou dans les régimes très
autoritaire
donc voilà y'a pas de tous les cas nous
ici on est plutôt dans une réflexion
sur
ouverte sur comment réussir à faire
qu'il puisse y avoir
un secteur de l'audiovisuel de la presse
même de la création puisque
l'audiovisuel touche pas seulement à
l'information qu'ils puissent être
puissant dans un monde très dur de
concurrence
notamment avec le numérique qui est
arrivé les plates formes tout en gardant
justement ce qui est une force et une
fierté française un système démocratique
d'une presse très diverses d'un
audiovisuel avec une régulation qui
justement faisait que la leur en on
essaie de faire vivre dans la couse qui
est nos principes constitutionnels de
liberté l'indépendance et le pluralisme
des médias donc c'est vraiment là-dessus
contraire c'est comment concilier et
faire en sorte que dans un univers où la
tendance est à la concentration parce
que il y a les géants du net eh bien on
n'écrase pas cette diversité ce
pluralisme qui ne passe par du
foisonnement par des petites entités
aussi qu'ils peuvent pour qui doit
pouvoir vivre par des niches et c est
pas par des monopoles qui était l'ancien
système de l'horaire tf
donc voilà
cette mise au point
ensuite une
deuxième remarque est une question
je suis très étonné de ce qu'on nous
avait répondu à monsieur caron et à moi
même je
vois là on et sera jugé 0 mais quand
même
commission denquête cette importance que
ce que l'on peut y dire je lis le compte
rendu du monde alors peut être qu'il y
avait eu un démenti de votre part je
comprendrais mais qui dit cette enquête
a notamment mis en milieu en lumière la
surveillance externe et puis dit
textuellement le groupe de bernard
arnault reconnaît ainsi les faits et
accepte de rézé autres et de régler au
trésor public une amende de 10 millions
d'euros contre l'extinction de l'action
bon donc vous avez dit absolument l'
inverse pour vous maintenez cette 1ère
micro monsieur arnaud parce que sinon on
ne va pas vous entendre
oui c'est la deuxième erreur de ce
journal que l'on a noté aujourd'hui
c'est faux on absolument pas reconnu de
culpabilité dans cette chose à mélisey
le document je je je je n'ai pas dit
culpabilité et moi je ne dirai vert
parce que j'ai pas enquêter c'est le
journal qui dit oui
reconnaît ainsi les faits
reconnaît ainsi n'est fait et d'ailleurs
ensuite tout le reste y compris de des
déclarations de vos représentants à
l'audience vont dans ce sens de dire que
y compris le ménage a été fait dans la
maison ce sont des faits anciens feux et
c'est pour ça qu'il est venu saisir ça
c'est bien ça le petit il n'y a aucune
culpabilité
de du groupe lvmh et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a signé ce document qu
à la demande de la justice
ensuite alors là la question elle est la
suivante qui est pour une précision
parce que je lui ai posé de façon
peut-être un peu vous avez dit en gros
que vous êtes rentré dans le secteur de
la presse à des moments où des titres
étaient en difficulté qu'on vous le
demander
je
pense qu'au printemps dernier
ou c'est vous qui avez fait une promesse
de rachat
le
une proposition pardon de rachat
pour le jdd et pour paris match vous me
confirmez scotch pareil uni dans la
presse à l'occasion de vous poser les
questions directement
alors qu'il y avait une négociation avec
monsieur bolloré
équipes ont probablement
examiner différentes choses mais on n'a
jamais fait proposer surnom
même précisément on dit que vous avez
fait une proposition d'un de 80 millions
donc ça vous ne confirmait pas non
très bien une question
question merci messieurs arnaud d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
[Musique]